[Music]
these santas are all really kids at
heart they like the fun and laughter
that comes with it and making people
happy that's why we're here
you ask them why they're saying most of
them will tell you because they enjoyed
being a child
so they're going back to that
they're reliving their childhood
it's a wonderful thing
welcome everyone to the charles w howard
80th anniversary santa claus school
[Music]
you better watch out you better not cry
i'm telling you why
santa claus is coming to town
[Music]
my name's tom valent i'm the dean of the
charles w howard santa claus school
in midland michigan
this is the harvard of santa schools
this is the oldest running santa claus
school in the world
it was started by charlie howard in 1937
at santa claus school we learn
everything from beard keeping to
personal hygiene what we're going to do
we're going to start with the base same
over here to toy making to what it feels
like to ride on the polar express
to flying the sleigh
[Music]
i want us to not be afraid of dance
santa has to be healthy
he's a healthy outdoorsman if you're not
healthy you're going to drift off you're
not going to pay attention
it's very important to have all the
skills you can to be a great santa
because the child is going to remember
this visit for the rest of your life oh
merry christmas
[Music]
when charlie had the school he had three
or four students some good years maybe
15 students this year we have 214. it
just grows
we have santa's of course from almost
every state in the united states we have
around 20 santas from canada we have
three santas from denmark one from
norway
and one from germany
there's a real sense of camaraderie in
this school
it's like this large santa family coming
together they share stories they learn
from each other
we want to be santas to make people
happy when we get together we're making
each other happy i love it
once they leave this school i hope that
each and every santa and mrs claus goes
out and spreads the spirit of christmas
spreads the love and joy that we have
here at this school
and passes it on to all the little
children and all the families
when you give joy you get it back
two-fold
you